[Musique]
je ne sais pas quoi dire pour la
première fois je ne sais pas quoi vous
raconter en fait cela fait environ sept
mois que j'ai annoncé cette vidéo
cependant je n'ai jamais réussi je n'ai
jamais eu le courage de la faire
et pourtant la voici interstellaire
n'est pas un film comme les autres il
est même certainement mon film préféré
et pourtant je n'aime pas beaucoup les
films réalistes dans l'espace et rares
sont les films qui arrivent à me toucher
comme celui là
j'aimerais vous faire passer un message
le temps est quelque chose de précieux
et d' assez effrayant peu importe
l'endroit le temps avancera et passera à
chaque seconde qui passe vous
vieillissez et votre vie avance le temps
peut s'accélérer s'étire et se ralentir
mais en aucun cas il ne peut s'inverser
on ne peut pas changer le passé on ne
peut pas revenir en arrière
peu importe nos actions le temps
avancera et s'écoulera et cela fait
partie de la nature
personnellement j'ai toujours vécu en
comptant le temps mes heures de sommeil
pour le lendemain mes années d'études ou
même pour ma chaîne youtube
c'est assez maladif j'ai peur du temps
qui passe et je me rends compte avec le
peu de temps de vie que j'ai passé avec
un de mes deux parents interstellar
mouse vers les yeux là dessus car malgré
la fiction de vrais messages se cache
dans ce film prenez le temps de vivre
votre vie fait ce qui vous importe le
plus le temps s'écoule et
personnellement je n'ai pas envie de
regretter plus tard
profitez de votre famille de vos proches
réaliser vos rêves fait ce qui vous
importe le plus nous n'avons qu'une
seule vie il faut en profiter
sept mois que je veux faire cette vidéo
par peur du sujet complexe du grand
chef-d'oeuvre cas interstellar et
pourtant c'est ce dernier qui m'a donné
conscience qu'il fallait que je prenne
le taureau par les cornes et que le
temps lui n'attend pas alors argot fait
cette vidéo que tu souhaites réalisés
depuis un moment et fonce tu en seras
fier
et finalement la voilà bref on ne va pas
s'attarder plus longtemps j'espère que
mon message ne vous aura pas trop ennuyé
mais je tenais vraiment à vous partager
ce dernier merci à ceux qui auront plus
le temps de l'écouter pour ceux qui ne
se rappellerait pas d'intéresser l'art
c'est un film de science fiction réalisé
par christopher nolan est sorti en 2014
on nous parle d'une espèce humaine se
situant dans le futur de notre monde
la nature se retourne finalement contre
nous c'est sans nous offrir de quoi
vivre
nous sommes arrivés à un temps où la
planète cesse de nous donner et nous
reprend ce qu'elle nous a fourni ce que
nous recherchons maintenant ce sont des
agriculteurs pour nourrir le monde
surpeuplé et dévasté mais cela ne suffit
pas il faut sauver l'humanité de
l'extinction est le seul moyen est de
quitter la terre l'homme est né sur
cette terre méridian l'obligent à y
rester hooper sera donc choisi pour
aller dans l'espace chercheurs une
nouvelle planète habitable pour l'espèce
humaine cependant le film ne s'arrête
pas un scénario si simple mais nous ne
sommes pas là pour ça interstellar est
un film qui s'est joué sur la corde
sensible et sur les philosophie de la
vie si vous ne l'avez jamais vu je vous
le conseille grandement
maintenant voici les théories
[Musique]
si vous avez regardé interstellar vous
avez forcément réfléchi pendant de
longues minutes sur la fin que nous
proposait le film cooper se laisse
tomber dans gargantua un vieux et
gigantesque trou noir car c'est le seul
et dernier moyen de peut-être pouvoir
sauver les habitants de la terre
cooper se fait donc aspirer et arrive
dans l'espace de la cinquième dimension
réalisé par des êtres du futur c'est à
ce moment tous à nous comprendre la
cinquième dimension qu'il parcourt est
en fait créé par les humains du futur
car le trou noir va modifier l'espace
temps il va donc être au final celui qui
va découvrir cette cinquième dimension
basé sur la gravité car il transmettra à
murphy sa fille le moyen de manipuler la
gravité solution du problème de
l'humanité via la vieille montre qui lui
avait offert quand elle était petite
cependant après avoir donné la solution
de l'équation à murphy le tesseract soit
l'endroit où se trouve cooper se
referment et nous passons à une scène
nous voyons cooper repasser dans le trou
de ver par lequel il était arrivé à la
base il croisera même le vaisseau avec
lequel il était arrivé prouvant que les
êtres de la cinquième dimension était
bien lui et donc les humains du futur
par la suite
et puis plus rien vide nous passons à la
scéno cooper est seul dans l'espace
inconscient il sera finalement repêché
par un vaisseau puis ramenés sur la
station créée par sa fille murphy qu'il
reverra une dernière fois par la suite
puis il ira retrouver brand à l'aube de
la découverte d'une nouvelle planète
potentiel pour le futur de l'humanité
mais est-ce que la fin du film est
réellement explicite à ce point je
dirais que non à en juger par notre
pensée
après avoir vu ce film on ne peut
s'empêcher de s'interroger sur cette fin
et j'ai envie de vous parler de la
théorie la plus connue sur interstellar
et elle peut changer considérablement
votre bise
de la fin du film d'après de nombreuses
personnes cooper vivre est en fait une
amy diminutive d'une expérience de mort
imminente
pour ceux qui ne sauraient pas ce qu'est
réellement une limite je vais vous
partager sa définition car c'était moi
même mon cas avant de faire cette vidéo
une expérience de mort imminente désigne
des sensations aux visions survenus chez
un individu alors qu'il était dans un
état de mort clinique où dans un coma
très profond
en gros lorsque vous mourrez votre
cerveau continue de fonctionner quelques
instants et vous transmet des visions
des souvenirs des rencontres
la célèbre théorie du tunnel avec la
lumière blanche au bout ceci fait partie
de la théorie des expériences de mort
imminente
le savon au ca grâce à certains
miraculés revenu d'entre les morts
mais tout ceci n'est que théorique donc
cooper serait mort après avoir quitté le
tesseract le corps errant dans l'espace
pourtant le film continue
pourquoi c'est une happy end beaucoup
trop puissante pour un film de ce genre
et il ne faut pas oublier que nous
sommes face à un film de christopher
nolan qui est un réel génie un message
doit être caché en premier lieu
rappelons nous des phrases prononcées
par matt damon alias dr man dans le film
voyez des machines pour ces missions les
machines pour la provision car on ne
peut pas programmer la peur de mourir
l'instinct de survie ray de loin notre
première source d'inspiration
tenez vous par exemple
à pairs dont l'instinct de survie
s'étend jusqu'à ses enfants et d'après
la recherche qu'elle est la dernière
chose que vous verrez avant de mourir
nos enfants
leurs visages à l'instant de la mort
votre cerveau va faire un effort un peu
plus grand pour survivre pour vos
enfants
il ne dis pas ça par hasard loin de là
quand cooper agonise suite à l' attaque
du docteur la première chose qu'ils
voient est sa fille murphy avec qu'il
possède un réel lien son cerveau fait un
dernier effort pour le maintenir en vie
il le restera par la suite je ne vous
dis pas ça par hasard une fois de plus
car si nous analysons la fin du film
après le coma de cooper nous sommes en
présence de scènes que le pilote rêver
et sauvegarde de l'humanité en sauvant
les gens de la terre sa maison revoir sa
fille murphy cooper s'imagine la vie
qu'il aurait aimé avoir après son
expérience dans la cinquième dimension
il savait que murphy serait très âgées
il en a parlé avec tard ce juste avant
son coma ou sa mort plus tôt il s'est
donc imaginer toute cette scène et de
nombreux indices vont dans le sens de
cette théorie
tout d'abord il faut savoir qu'aucun
être humain ne peut survivre à la
pression gravitationnelle d'un trou noir
et il pourrait même que cooper soient
morts directement en entrant dans cargo
toi c'est d'ailleurs une grosse critique
interstellar a subi tous les films
seraient trop dans la science fiction
mais justement christopher nolan sait ce
qu'il fait et il a réalisé le film avec
kip thorne une référence mondiale des
trous noirs la mort imminente serait le
message caché du film
cooper possède un lien puissant avec sa
fille murphy et la voix dans toutes ces
visions et cela va de même s'il doit
mourir
on ne voit d'ailleurs jamais tom son
fils aîné dans ses visions la fin y
compris on ne voit que murphy âgées en
supposerait qu'il est mort car il était
plus âgé que murphy
mais justement couleur or est intégré le
fait que tom soient déjà morts de
vieillesse son souhait véritable était
de retrouver murphy
même si elle était très âgé et c'est le
cas à la fin on peur se réveille dans la
station suite à son pseudo comme à nous
avons l'image d'une station en forme de
tube sûrement dû à la manipulation de la
gravité mais
trop vision que nous arriver le tube
pourrait symboliser l'image du fameux
tunnel avec la lumière au bout
lorsque nous mouvons lorsque cooper se
réveille il est au début du tunnel mais
plus le temps avance et plus la mort
arrive et d'après moi le dernier passage
du film avec murphy en est la clé
ce passage est d'une puissance
incommensurable et me donne des frissons
incroyable cooper entre dans la chambre
de ma fille allongée sur son lit et là
quelque chose de très étrange arrive
tout le monde s'écarte en regardant
cooper et le laisse en compagnie de sa
fille
cooper ne regarde absolument personne la
famille est juste là pour symboliser la
famille justement tous ces visages sont
inconnus et très peu exploitées car
cooper n'a justement aucune connaissance
de ses petits enfants
et comme dans un rêve imagine des
visages pour représenter ses petits
enfants ils sont juste là pour
symboliser la famille comme je l'aï dit
en aucun cas il leur parle et son regard
se tourne seulement vers murphy
d'ailleurs cette famille semble aussi
ignoré leurs aïeuls qui a sauvé pourtant
l'humanité puisque murphy lors à tout
expliquer
ce n'est vraiment pas anodin quand
murphy dit à son père de partir
rejoindre rendre c'est à ce moment
précis que le rêve s'arrête
le plan est filmée de telle façon que
cela nous donne l'impression d'un retour
arrière en mode la famille se rapproche
alors qu'ils s'écartaient et cache la
vue de cooper vers murphy comme quand il
est arrivé dans la chambre
ce plan n'est vraiment pas filmer
seulement pour la beauté du film
cela cache réellement quelque chose
copper s'en va donc rejoindre brand
il prend un vaisseau et retourne dans
l'espace la fin du voyage et donc du
rêve
copper prend finalement le tunnel et
s'en va pour retourner là où il nous
avait précédemment quitter dans l'espace
il a finalement revu murphy l'objet
principal de son fantasme de mort
imminente et nous quitte finalement en
paix en voulant rejoindre brand qui
symbolise la mission qu'il a toujours
voulu
réussite la survie de l'humanité en
déplaçant les humains de la terre vers
une autre planète que nous ne pouvons
pas encore comprendre c'est peut-être
témoignages la marque d'une dimension
supérieure que nous pouvons pas encore
consciemment percevoir
je vais à l'autre bout de l'univers
attiré par un homme parti il y a dix ans
et qui selon toute vraisemblance est
mort de toutes les choses que nous
percevons seul l'amour trans anglais
dimension temporelle et spatiale
peut-être bien qu'on devrait accepter en
confiance ce qu'on ne saisit pas encore
[Musique]
je ne sais pas si on peut catégoriser
ceci comme une théorie mais je tenais
réellement en parler l'amour est quelque
chose d'important et de très présent
dans interstellar et nous le voyons
principalement grâce au lien qui unit
cooper et sa fille murphy ce soir même
au final l'amour que cooper porte avec
sa fille qui lui permettra de donner la
solution à murphy pour qu'elles sauvent
les habitants de la terre
eh bien je me demande si l'amour ne
serait pas en fait la cinquième
dimension justement enfin la cinquième
dimension serait le temps mais l'amour y
serait pour quelque chose
comme il est dit pour la professeure
bande l'amour et quantifiables et
transcende le temps et l'espace
peu importe la distance peu importe la
durée l'amour ne changera pas vous savez
on dit souvent que les jumeaux ou même
une mère avec son enfant savent quand ce
qu'ils aiment vont mal malgré une grande
distance bien pourquoi pas il faut
savoir que dans interstellar l'amour est
doué au final deux raisons la passion
permet finalement la raison
nous avons le cas des coupeurs dans la
cinquième dimension mais aussi avec le
professeur brand qui trouvera au final
la future planète habitable pour les
humains celle du professeur moon ce dont
elle était amoureuse
on pourrait même supposer qu'après que
cooper sont inconscients dans l'espace
le destin l'amour de sa fille il est
conduit jusqu'à elle pour la fin après
tout il est tout donner pour elle ce
serait une belle image
l'amour est quelque chose de grand et de
bon pour l'homme comme pour le reste du
monde
il faut savoir qu'un chien par exemple
élevé avec amour serein à chiens en
meilleure santé il voir plus intelligent
qu'un chien élevé dans la peur ou j'ose
même pas imaginer un chien heureux élevé
avec amour pour apprendre des tours et
chercher le journal bref j'en passe tout
ce que vous voulez mais pour apprendre
tout ceci seulement s'il est heureux
peu importe l'animal l'amour permet de
grandes choses l'humain par amour peut
faire de grandes actions aussi c'est une
source de bonheur de force et de
détermination sans faille
malheureusement nous le voyons dans
notre monde actuel
l'amour n'est pas forcément quelque
chose de présent à part dans votre
famille ou avec vos amis ou si vous avez
un copain ou une copine mais cela reste
intime
notre monde est divisé par la politique
la religion ou encore autre domaine le
message que je vous faire passer n'est
pas de vous aimer je ne vous dirai pas
ça mais c'est que nous connaissons
finalement peu de choses sur nous mêmes
et sur le monde car nous vivons ces
choses actuelles l'amour de la nature ne
fait pas réellement partie de l'espèce
humaine même si je me doute que comme
moi beaucoup aiment les animaux etc
l'amour pourrait faire évoluer l'humain
et lui faire faire de grandes choses jeu
paraît que certains d'entre vous ont
déjà tenté des choses improbables car il
était amoureux ou amoureuse de quelqu'un
mais avouez que sans le fait d'être
amoureux vous n'aurez rien fait l'amour
conduite au bonheur à la passion et
c'est ce que d'humains recherche un
homme heureux travaille mieux et est en
meilleure santé
voilà un message que m'a fait comprendre
interstellar l'amour transcende le temps
et l'espace
et c'est la seule chose qui le peut vous
pouvez être à mille années-lumière de là
r vous aimerez toujours autant vos
proches et vous penserez à peu enfin
comme à damon dit à cooper que la
dernière chose qu'il verrait en
mouvement ce serait ses enfants ce n'est
pas pour rien qu'on cerveau comme il le
dit fort atteint dernier effort de
survie en revoyant leur visage pour
survivre et c'est le cas pour tout le
monde quand on dit qu'on a vu notre vie
défiler devant nos yeux c'est exactement
la même chose
nous revoyons les moments marquants de
bonheur des moments avec nos proches
donc d'amour l'amour décuple nos
sensations notre puissance et pourrait
bien faire évoluer l'humain comme
découvrir une cinquième dimension encore
inconnue pour ce dernier
enfin pour terminer ce pourrait-il qu'un
interstellar 2 fasse son apparition un
jour c'est ce que nous allons voir tout
de suite y interstellaire se finit d'un
coup et fut un succès énorme et même si
certains pensent que le film aurait pu
se terminer dix minutes plus tôt
beaucoup souhaiteraient un deuxième film
mais je ne suis pas trop de cet avis
personnellement mais cela reste possible
cooper est encore vivant et il lui reste
de nombreuses années à vivre
la mission n'est toujours pas terminée
murphy a fait le plus gros du travail
grâce à la solution sur la montre mais
les humains ne sont toujours pas sur une
planète habitable
ils sont seulement sur une plateforme
spatiale brand retrouver la planète
habitable que chercheur l espèce humaine
hooper ira même la rejoindre avant que
le film ne s'arrête brusquement une
suite pourrait donc être créés cooper et
bande terminerait la mission en
déplaçant l'espèce humaine sur la
planète de mousse ou bien on pourrait
retrouver cooper et brand dans le futur
où l'humanité serait installé sur la
nouvelle planète
la conquête spatiale pourrait alors
reprendre et cooper et brand irait donc
visiter les autres planètes des deux
astronautes partis en mission à l'époque
après tout l'humain maîtriserait la
cinquième dimension cette fois ci donc
pourquoi pas mais au final qu'est ce que
ce second opus
s'il y en avait un apporterait
interstellar ne traite pas seulement
d'une histoire de science fiction
c'est un film qui reste tout de même
réaliste au niveau de l'humanité et film
a su manier avec grandeur des
philosophies de vie qui sont importantes
et nous fait passer des messages
nécessaires
l'amour est un bon exemple l'amour
pourrait être la clé de tout comme je le
disais auparavant
peu importe l'espace temps vous aimerez
toujours autant vos proches
le temps fait partie aussi vivre sa vie
réaliser ce que nous voulons faire est
important le temps n'attend pas et
avance constamment quel message ce
second film pourrait apporter
je pense qu'un deuxième opus casserait
ce père construit le premier quart la
surprise ne serait plus là et la
grandeur d'un terreau stellar perdrait
en valeur
il est très difficile donc lire une
coupe qui est déjà pleine et si un
deuxième film a été réalisé il serait
beaucoup trop dans la science fiction
car trop dans le futur néanmoins il est
tout à fait possible qu'un deuxième opus
existe un jour aucune info pour le
moment mais ce serait probable mais
connaissant christopher nolan
on peut se gratter à part si quelqu'un
reprendrait le flambeau mais comme je
les dis le film perdrait en valeur je
suis peut être mauvaise langue et 6,1
interstellaire de devait sortir je serai
le premier à aller le voir
mais d'après moi on ne peut continuer ce
chef-d'oeuvre et nous devons le laisser
tranquille
après tout comme beaucoup le disent le
film aurait pu se terminer avant la fin
déjà proposé je me souviens quand j'ai
vu interstellaire la première fois je ne
voulais pas le voir car je crois que
c'était un film comme tous les graffitis
like
j'ai beaucoup de mal avec les films
pseudo réaliste dans l'espace et
pourtant je me suis pris une claque
tellement violente interstellar m'a fait
grandir et mûrir et je suis très heureux
lui avoir rendu hommage ce n'est pas
tous les jours que nous avons des films
de ce genre et j'espère que ce ne sera
pas le dernier
mais ça sera vraiment dur de le dépasser
dans mon coeur si vous souhaitez voir un
film grandiose un peu dans le même style
je vous conseille premier contact sortie
assez récemment
enfin voila je ne vois pas quoi rajouter
j'espère que cette vidéo et météorites
vous auront plus merci à tous d'être là
et de me suivre
vous êtes au jour de plus en plus à
écouter mes théories et ça fait vraiment
chaud au coeur
merci à ceux qui laisseront un pouce
bleus et qui partageront la vidéo
n'hésitez pas à me suivre sur twitter
pour les plus acharnés d'entre vous
c'était votre dévoué
art baroque et que le line up soit avec
vous et à jamais
[Musique]